hey i'm ryan i'm david and we're here to
review x-men days of future past trailer
number two i know david's excited as am
i let's get into it david first shot we
think that this is new york that looks
like the empire state building yeah for
sure and we think we're gonna go through
the building we see what i think what
used to be central park and is now the
concentration camps the mutants are
being put in which comes from the comics
in which all these uh mutants get put
into camps um
david mused before what if that hole in
the middle of the empire state building
was an x yeah i wonder if that would be
cooler or less cool i don't know i think
it'd be less cool what do you think
comment below so we see a lot of these
carrier ships that we see later carrying
sentinels which are a huge part of the
x-men universe and a very big part of
this movie and as you all know we go we
time travel in this movie we see young
magneto and old magneto and young xavier
now
that was a sentinel it was kind of like
the t2
uh the tx who can like sort of change
liquid form looks like like the sentinel
can change the hand or like i'll tell
you what david it looks like storm's in
some trouble in this scene yeah i don't
know how she's gonna get out of this one
lightning won't help you there anyway
um so this movie bat hat harry that's
brian singer's production company this
movie was directed by brian singer
director of the first two anyway this is
what i was talking about with the
carrier ships letting out the sentinels
um
so
again the biggest thing about this movie
the cast is humongous yeah we even have
colossus here from
yeah there are a few shots of newer uh
mutants there's colossus that is sunspot
or sunflower yeah sunspot a lot of i'm
sure a lot of people saw it and said the
human torch is in this movie yeah and
david says no
that's not right so his powers that he
can turn into a son
um and then that's we're still in the
future
um so you were telling me that in the
comic books it's kitty pride who goes
back in time goes back in time and they
sent her consciousness back in time this
one because wolverine is more popular
they send wolverines basically his
assault his mind back into the time
um and a huge they're really playing up
the bryant stinger angle of this whole
thing you were telling me
that they had to rebuild this blue
hallway yeah because they tore it down
after the last x-men movie
because why would they save these things
but it's cool to see there's nick
holty's uh he's hank mccoy
aka beast in the background
um and that is the outside of cerebro
yeah the big um that plays a huge part
in x2
so
the idea of them kind of bringing
together the continuity of all of the
movies is kind of crazy
and impressive yeah i mean this is a
huge cast i mean the budget for this is
260 million dollars which i assume a lot
just would go with salaries for the
actors for sure and as you were saying
before special effects i'm sure it was a
huge part of the budget
it's not all of it there's a pause yeah
we see quicksilver wearing a pink floyd
shirt and silver hair which i'm not a
fan of at all we've
we're not happy with the quick silver
look um in the background there's
someone tied up with duct tape and it
looks like quicksilver did it very
quickly if someone took their time with
that duct tape the craftsmanship is so
why is james mcavoy able to stand we
don't know and it's very confusing and
is he all wet or does he just not wash
his hair that's important to know for
the story
um
i believe that's magneto getting his
helmet back yeah and i like the classic
look of the helmet in this it's you know
it looks just like the comic books at
the end of first class they showed
magneto um in his kind of like classic
outfit which is right and this is the
vietnam war era so i assume we're at a
vietnam war yeah and camp or something
this is kind of like a souped-up version
of mystiques like it's they've kind of
changed how she's transformed throughout
the movies um that's really
always kind of an interesting facet of
her character
um
it's just legs they're waving that looks
yeah
what's that the flags are waving what we
don't know what flag that is do we i i
don't i don't i don't know if that's an
actual flag we were talking about how
cool this looks to in an action movie if
someone does an a big grand action while
looking for something
it always looks very nonchalant and cool
and michael fassbender is kind of the
master of women
there's peter dinklage who's famous from
uh game of thrones who plays bolivar
trask who invented all the sentinels yes
which again are a huge part of this
movie and we see a really good yeah so
that's probably where you assume this is
the 70s that's probably like the first
sentinel and then as we saw earlier
about to attack storm that's like the
more advanced sentinel that can change
shape yeah there's a ton of different
kind of models throughout the whole
thing
um
there's a shot coming up here now that
mutant is called blink and from what
i've read she can teleport and send
things through portals
so kind of like nightcrawler except she
can throw it to other people yeah
there's kitty pride and there's a bishop
with a huge gun which is sort of always
something his character always has huge
guns yeah bishop seeing bishop on screen
is a really cool thing because he's kind
of the some peripheral character in the
comic books that never really kind of
got
a movie treatment so that's really cool
that's a very matrixy looking shot of
the robots
if you go back there his blood is purple
or something and i assume that's to get
a good rating on the trailer they can't
show explicit blood doesn't sit right
with david that is blood his blood is i
said that perhaps he was eating
cranberry juice before everybody came in
um
i don't think that's that's ellen page
that's kitty pride yeah right there yeah
yeah um she featured more prominently in
x-men the last stand i don't even was
she in the previous ones as a cameo she
did
i don't think that kitty pride was in x2
but it wasn't ellen page until they kind
of wrote a bigger part for her
there's a bunch of sentinels and now i
wonder if the sentinels can be
controlled by magneto if they're made of
plastic or some kind of metal
um
oh that was havoc yeah he was in x-men
uh first class that's supposed to be a
cyclops brother uh alex summers and he
in first class he shoots out of his
chest but here looks like he can control
it by his arms now it's really it's
really fascinating to me um
how they're really kind of seamlessly
joining these two worlds because to me
x-men first class kind of took place in
this
alternate i never connected the two in
my mind like it was a reboot and the
fact that they're taking their reboot
and combining it with their original
franchise is kind of exciting and
unexpected and now they're planning on
doing a few of these
with x-men apocalypse if you saw there
we could saw just blink throws something
pink that opens up like a portal
and then we see what
ten-year-old me would be so psyched to
see that's ice man
it's like ice gliding maneuvers which is
so cool yeah especially after in
x-men the last stand
the the ice man kind of turning into ice
was very disappointing so pause so that
was sure of course uh james mcavoy
that's young charles xavier and old and
now i don't really know how who's time
traveling is what i'm wondering i can't
understand exactly how they are meeting
and i have a feeling this is happening
inside one of their heads
that's what i think
but then still they need to get back in
time yeah so or forward i don't it looks
like maybe they're in a living room like
it looks like there could be a
chandelier and a painting on them yeah
they perhaps are in the mansion yeah the
charles xavier mansion i mean he spent
all the money on the real estate he
might as well stay in it you know anyway
um so
days of future past
super exciting um comes out here may
23rd
comes out in jamaica may 20th
so any of our jamaican viewers you get
it three days before we do so please let
us know how it is david are you excited
i'm excited i really hope this movie's
five hours long because that's like if
it's shorter than that then i'm gonna be
a little disappointed but i hope i don't
know what the runtime is yet but if it's
five hours i'll be really happy i'm
gonna be honest david i think you might
be a little disappointed
chance of this being five hours long is
very but you know what we still hope
there's still gonna be x-men apocalypse
in 2016 also directed by brian singer
yeah who and what i've read in
interviews it's supposed to be the
younger cast so maybe jennifer lawrence
will be in that one yeah
so i think this is a great trailer
everything we've seen from this movie is
kind of awesome and the comic-con
reaction was huge uh so no reason to
believe this will be anything less than
the best film ever made yeah that will
be five hours long so comment below let
us know what you think and until next
time i'm ryan and i'm david thank you
for watching